okay so what does the equality act
actually do so ryan anderson
who has been basically book burned by
amazon they took down his book when
harry became sally
even though it is a it is a well-written
concise and yes tolerant book about
transgenderism
he says over and over and over that
people who suffer from gender dysphoria
should be treated
with the greatest of care which is
absolutely true
it is a semblance of how idiotic our
society has become that we now say that
a man with a mental disorder namely
gender dysphoria is a woman
okay that is that is not how that works
and yes it is a mental disorder
according to the dsm-4
gender dysphoria is a mental disorder
according to the dsm-5 by the way
it used to be called gender identity
dysphoria a gender identity disorder
then they renamed it gender dysphoria
because they added a requirement
in the dsm-5 the diagnostic and
statistical manual five
that it's not just that you identify as
a member of the opposite sex it's that
it causes you depression which is the
dumbest standard
for diagnosing a mental illness ever a
mental disorder
ever by that standard if you walk around
saying
that you are jesus christ today you are
not suffering from any sort of mental
disorder
unless it also causes you distress to
say that okay that's a ridiculous
standard
it doesn't hold by virtually any other
definition of a mental disorder but
that is what the the pseudoscientists
over at the american psychological
association have to say about all of us
in any case
what exactly does the equality act do so
ryan anderson writes about this
the act updates the law congress passed
primarily to combat racism the civil
rights act of 1964
and adds sexual orientation and gender
identity as protected classes akin to
race
so if you have any reservations about
gender ideology as even many
progressives do you now be the legal
equivalent of bull conor right to say
that men and women exist and that they
are separate
and that a man who believes he is a
woman is not actually a woman and that a
man who enters a women's locker room
with all the male appendages and says he
is a woman should not be allowed to do
so this makes you
like a 1960s jim crow era racist
okay now to suggest that the differences
between black people and white people
are anywhere akin to the differences
between men and women
is patently crazy the differences
between black people and white people do
not matter
they're essentially skin deep that is
the whole point
the difference between men and women is
a lot more than skin deep
it affects nearly every area of
intrasexual relationships
it affects how men and women develop
physically it affects how men and women
developmentally there are significant
differences in mental development
between men and women
women have advantages in some areas men
have advantages in some areas but there
are major differences
this is all well-established science
there is not a single thing i am saying
right now that is conjecture
what is conjecture is the suggestion
that sex is completely malleable
what the left has done here is they play
a game here's how the game works
they accept supposedly that sex is
non-malleable
then they say gender is different from
sex so what is gender gender is a
collection of stereotypes
about femininity and masculinity okay
but now that they're stereotypes you're
saying that they're arbitrary right
because they're stereotypes they're not
connected to any sort of underlying
biological reality and yet you say
that gender is so important and so real
that those stereotypes
actually make you a man or a woman so
now sex doesn't matter
right so sex which is the only thing
that we can objectively tell that
doesn't matter
because gender identity which a second
ago was a set of stereotypes that were
supposedly foisted upon you by an
intolerant society
those are the only things that matter so
if a man cross-dresses and dresses up as
a woman
and this makes him transgender
interested perhaps right maybe he's
actually
a girl but it depends on his
self-definition if he's a man who just
likes wearing a dress
then for sure he's just a man but if
he's a man who likes wearing a dress and
also thinks he's a woman then he is a
transgender person
if none of this makes any scientific
sense to you that's because it has
nothing to do with science it is in fact
an ideology
it is not in fact scientifically rooted
it is it is
based entirely on the fallacy that
sexual that biological sex and
gender characteristics are completely
different and yet gender characteristics
matter more than biological sex
and then what you will see is the final
move which says well actually we're
going to go back to that whole thing
about sexual dichotomy it doesn't exist
so you'll see this from the left a lot
you see you know there are people who
have xx chromosomes or xy chromosomes
and who manifest as a member of the
other sex because of a developmental
disorder yes it's called the
developmental disorder
if if i say that human beings
walk upright that that is a true
statement
now are there certain human beings who
are born with a disability
and cannot walk upright yes does that
mean that as a class of human beings
human beings do not walk upright no it
means that some people have disorders
okay that does not mean that you
redefine that exact term
okay the what what people on the left
like to do is take edge cases
right they like to take genetic
anomalies and then treat those as though
this creates entire new classes of human
beings this is incorrect
it is not right and it's all
it's all ridiculous but this has become
the new normal so now they're trying to
enshrine this into law and this has some
pretty dire ramifications for your
freedoms
everything from freedom of association
to freedom of religion to freedom of the
press
to freedom of speech all of it is going
to be ground down under the boot heel
of an authoritarian left that decides
that basic truth should be verboten
okay it is a basic truth that men and
women exist and exist on the basis of
biological characteristics that are
objectively verifiable
that is a simple reality if you die
today
there will be people a hundred years
from now who will be able to look at
your dna and they will be able to tell
whether you're a man or a woman and your
subjective self-identification will
matter not one wit
because all you will be at that point is
bones we will be able to know whether
you are in fact a man or a woman
simply by looking at your bone structure
we do this right now in archaeology
we can tell what sex your baby is before
they are born
according to left by the way you can't
tell somebody's actual gender until they
die
and even then you can't use their
biology because your gender could switch
any minute
there are people who are 45 years old
who have been a man all their life and
have sired seven children
and if they decide they're a woman they
were not only are they a woman they were
always a woman
because not only does transgender
ideology violate the boundaries of
biology it violates the boundaries of
physics
it's incredible it's a time machine you
have to erase
every vestige of the idea that this
person was ever a man
right it's not just that bruce jenner
changed his name and became caitlyn
jenner and had some surgeries
that is not what happened kate bruce
jenner was always caitlyn jenner bruce
jenner was always a woman you see
while winning medals at the olympics
which makes him the most accomplished
female athlete ever by the way
right so it turns out that biological
men are even the best female athletes
it's incredible
but now this is going to be written into
law and it's you're going to be
cudgelled with it and your children will
be cuddled with it
let's not pretend that this is anything
but what it is it's an authoritarian
move by the left to cuddle everyone into
line
it's an exercise of absolute raw power
that is the attempt right here
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content